like the concept of the mole balancing
equations is one of those ideas that you
learn in first year chemistry class that
tends to give a lot of students a hard
time even though it is a fairly
straightforward concept i think what
makes it difficult is that there's a bit
of an art to it so before we talk about
balancing chemical equations what is a
chemical equation well here's some
examples right here and have some more
in the rest of this video but
essentially just describes a chemical
reaction you got some aluminum you have
some oxygen gas
or or diatomic oxygen molecule and then
you end up with aluminum oxide and you
say okay fine that's an equation it
looks nice i have my reactants or the
things that react these are the
reactants and then i have the products
of this reaction what do what's left
there to do well you have a problem here
the way i've written it right now i have
one atom of aluminum
plus two atoms of oxygen right they're
bonded to each other but there's two
atoms of oxygen here one molecule of
diatomic oxygen or one
molecule of oxygen but they have two
oxygen atoms here when you add them
together what do i have two atoms of
aluminum and three atoms of oxygen so i
have a different number of aluminums on
both sides of this equation on this side
i have one aluminum
on this side i have two aluminums and
then i have a different number of
oxygens on this side i have two oxygens
and on that side i have three oxygens so
balancing equations is all about fixing
that problem so i have the same number
of aluminum on both sides of the
equation and the same number of oxygens
on both sides so let's try to do that
i'll do it in orange
so i said just when i said i have one
aluminum here and i have two aluminums
there so maybe a simple thing is just to
put a 2 out here so now i have
2 aluminums on this side and i have 2
aluminums on this side the aluminums
look happy now let's look at the oxygen
here i have 2 oxygens on the left hand
side of the equation and on the right
hand side of the equation i have three
oxygens what can i do here
well if if i could kind of have half
atoms i could just multiply this by one
and a half
1.5
1.5 times two is three so now i have
three oxygens on both sides of this
equation and i have two aluminums on
both sides equation am i done well no
you can't have half an atom or one and a
half of an atom that's that's not cool
so what you do is you just multiply this
so that you end up with whole numbers so
let's just multiply both sides of this
whole equation
by two and we have
four aluminums
plus three
oxygens
yields we multiplied everything by two
two
molecules
of aluminum
oxide
now you might have been tempted at some
point in this exercise to say oh well
why don't i just tweak part of the
aluminum oxide why don't i put a
two-thirds in front of this oxygen you
cannot do that the the equation is as it
is the molecule aluminum oxide is
aluminum oxide you can't change the the
relative ratios of the aluminum and the
oxygen within the aluminum oxide
molecule you can just change the number
of aluminum oxide molecules as a whole
that you have in this case two so what
did we do we looked at the aluminum we
said okay we need two aluminums to have
both sides of that b2
and then when we looked at oxygen we say
well if i multiply this by one and a
half then that becomes three oxygens
here because one and a half times two
oxygens and three oxygen is there and
then all we said is well i can't have a
one and a half there so let me multiply
both sides by two and i ended up with
four aluminums plus
three
oxygen molecules or six oxygen atoms
yields two molecules of aluminum oxide
let's see if we can do some more of
these so here i have methane and that g
in parentheses i just wanted to expose
you to that that just means it's a gas
so i have methane gas plus oxygen gas
yields carbon dioxide gas plus water and
that's an l there so liquid water so
what can we do here
so the general thing is do the
complicated molecules first and then at
the end you can worry about the single
the single atom molecules because those
are very easy to to play with and the
reason why you do that when whenever you
change a number here let's say we're
trying to engineer how many carbons we
have on both sides of this equation if i
set a number here i'm also changing the
number of hydrogens and i'll have to
play with the hydrogens there at the end
i'll have some number of oxygens and i
have to tweak this number right there so
let's let's let's just start with the
carbons
it seems complicated when you go step by
step and you kind of play with things a
little bit it should proceed fairly
smoothly
so here i have two carbons two carbons
and here i have on the right hand side i
only have one carbon
so ideally i'd want two carbons on both
sides of this equation so let me put a
two out here
so there you go my carbons are happy i
now have two carbons and two carbons
now let me move to the hydrogens
remember i wanted to do the oxygen's
last because i can just set this to
whatever i want it to be without messing
up any of the other atoms
so on this side of the equation i have
four hydrogen atoms how many hydrogen
atoms do i have on this side of the
equation see so i have four hydrogen
atoms here
how many do i have on this side
well i have two hydrogen atoms right
there
so i want to have 4 on both sides so let
me put a 2 in front of the water
so now i have 4 hydrogen atoms cool
finally oxygen on the left hand side
i have 2 oxygen atoms
and on the right hand side what do i
have
i have two times this one oxygen right
here so right now that's two
right two waters and each water have one
oxygen atom but i have two oxygen i have
i have two water molecules have two
oxygens and then i have in the carbon
dioxide i have two oxygen in each carbon
dioxide and have two carbon dioxides
right when i put that magenta two out
front so how many oxygens do i have two
times two i have four oxygens
so on the left hand side i have two
oxygens
on the right hand side i have six
oxygens two and the two molecules of
water and four in the two molecules of
carbon dioxide
so how do i make this two into six i
wanna have six oxygens on this side i
want them to have six oxygens on the
left hand side as well well if i put a
three out here
if i put a three out here now i have
six oxygens and my equation has been
balanced i have two carbons on this side
two carbons on that side
four hydrogens on this side four
hydrogens on this side six oxygens on
this side and then four plus two six
oxygens on that side
next equation to balance this actually
becomes quite fun once you once you get
the knack of it
so i have i have ethane
i have ethane plus oxygen gas
yielding
carbon dioxide and water
so this is a combustion process
so let's look at the carbons first i
have two carbons here i have one carbon
there
so let me put a two here
so now i have two carbons
fair enough remember i'm going to worry
about the oxygen last this one's
actually not too different than the last
problem
i have six hydrogens here
i only have two hydrogens in the water
so i only have three hydrogen molecules
or three water molecules and now i've
balanced out the hydrogens i have six
hydrogens on both sides of the equation
and now let's do a deal with the water
here on the right hand side
i have i'll do it in this orange color
i have
two oxygens in each carbon dioxide
molecule and i have two molecules so i
have four oxygens
and i have
one oxygen in each water molecule and i
have three molecules have three oxygens
here is that right
three oxygens on the right hand side yup
three water molecules and then i have
four oxygens in the carbon dioxide right
so i have seven oxygens i have seven
oxygens on this side and i only have two
on this side so how can i make this two
into seven
well i can multiply it by three and a
half
right remember i just wanna have seven
on both sides if i have three and a half
of these diatomic oxygen molecules three
and a half times two is seven so now i
have seven oxygens on both hand both
sides of the equation four plus three
and seven here two carbons and then six
hydrogens and i'm almost done except for
the fact that you can't have fractions
of molecules so what you do is just
multiply both sides of the equation by
two or three or whatever you need to
multiply it to get rid of the fraction
so if i multiply everything by two i end
up with two molecules
of ethane
plus
seven molecules
of diatomic oxygen
seven o2s
yielding
two molecules of carbon dioxide
oh sorry i'm multiplying everything by
two so four molecules of carbon dioxide
let me
four molecules of carbon dioxide plus
six molecules
of water and if you just to make sure
that that all still works if you want to
you can check how much carbon do we have
i have four carbons here i have four
carbons here
how much hydrogen do i have i have two
times six
i have 12 hydrogens here i have 12
hydrogens here how much oxygen do i have
i have
let me do a different color i have 14
oxygens here and here i have
eight oxygens
and here i have six times one i have six
oxygen so six plus eight is fourteen so
my equation has been balanced so that
one a lot of people might have find that
to be a hard problem because you have
this three and a half and just going
straight to this might seem
non-intuitive but if you just work from
the more complicated
molecules and you go atom by atom and if
you end up with any fractions you just
multiply both sides by some number to
get rid of the fraction and then you're
done
all right let's do another one
so this one looks all hairy i have this
i have this
iron
iron oxide plus sulfuric acid yields
this all this hairy stuff but the key
here to realize is that
this group right here
this sulfate group the sulfate group
stays together
right you have this so4 there and you
have this so4 there
so to really simplify things for our
head you can kind of treat that like an
atom so let's make a substitution we'll
substitute that for x
and so if we rewrite this
as
i'll do it in a vibrant color
iron
oxide
plus
h2
there's only one sulfate group here so
h2 i'm doing this x
and then that yields
that yields
iron
two irons this molecule two irons and
has three of these sulfate groups
three of these sulfate groups and then
plus water
all i did is replace the sulfate with an
x and now we can treat that x like an
atom and we can just balance the
equation
so let's see on the left hand side how
many irons do we have we have two irons
here we have two irons there so the
irons look
balanced at first glance let's deal with
the oxygens
so if we have
three oxygens here let me do it in a
different color
we have three oxygens here
and we only have one oxygen here
remember there were some oxygen in this
x group but those the x
the the sulfate group stayed together so
we can just treat those separately
so if we have we want to have three
oxygens on the right hand side as well
so let's take a three here
whoops
let's take a
sometimes my pen tool and malfunctions
so let me put that three there so now we
have three oxygens as well and then
finally let's see let's look at the
let's look at the hydrogens
so i have
or maybe i should we have three let's
see how many hydrogens we have here we
have six hydrogens now
on the right hand side
six hydrogens here three times two and
we wanna have six hydrogens here so we
have to have three of these molecules
and then finally let's look at the
sulfate group that x we have three x's
here
we have three x's here and lucky for us
we have three x's
over there so our equation has been
balanced and if we wanna write it back
in terms of the sulfate terms we can
just
unsubstitute the x and we're left with
iron one molecule of iron oxide plus
three molecules of sulfuric acid h2
so4 i just unsubstitute the x with so4
yields
one of these molecules
so4 3
4 3 i just unsubstituted the x
plus 3 molecules
of water
let's do one more and then i think we'll
be all balanced out
carbon dioxide plus hydrogen gas yields
methane plus water so let's deal with
the carbons first
i have one carbon here one carbon there
the carbons look happy let's look at the
oxygen i have two oxygens here
i have one oxygen there so i want two
oxygens here so let me stick a two there
and then let's deal with the hydrogen's
last because this is the easiest one to
play with because it doesn't affect any
of the other atoms
so if the hydrogen i have 2 here and i
have 4
plus 4 here right i have 4 hydrogens
there and i have four hydrogens there so
i need eight hydrogens on the left hand
side so i just put a four there and
we're all done balancing anyway
hopefully you found that useful